nous avec françois cocq poursuivre cette
manifestation cet après midi on se
disait contre la loi sécurité globale
françois comme on le voit sur ces images
en direct de vives tensions place de la
bastille entre des groupes de casseurs
et les forces de l'ordre on a vu
certains manifestants d'ailleurs demandé
à ces casseurs finalement de de ne pas
venir ternir cette manifestation des
scènes philco le voir finalement très
régulièrement tous les samedis depuis
maintenant un peu plus de deux ans avec
les gilets jaunes qu'est ce que ça
révèle d écouter les casseurs vire
évidemment ne servent absolument pas la
cause qu'ils prétendent défendre et au
contraire ils l'affaiblissent et le
grand nombre qui est celle de qui était
celui de toutes celles et de tous ceux
qui manifestent pacifiquement mais de
manière extrêmement déterminé celui-là a
besoin et que son message soit
aujourd'hui clairement est largement
entendu et je crois qu'il l'ait vu la
mobilisation populaire qui est celle là
mais ce qui ressort des images que nous
avons sous les yeux
finalement c'est une forme de chaos
aujourd'hui de chaos permanent dans ce
pays dont le responsable se trouve à
l'elysée
enfin si nous avons une situation dans
laquelle aujourd'hui les forces de
l'ordre ne peuvent pas intervenir devant
ces casseurs finalement sont pieds et
poings liés
c'est bien parce qu'aujourd'hui elles
ont perdu une part de leur légitimité
et pourquoi ont-elles perdu cette part
de leur légitimité parce que celles et
ceux qui sont les décideurs leur ont
fait faire des actions totalement
absurde leur ont donné des consignes qui
n'ont rien à voir avec la bonne gestion
républicaine des manifestations et de et
de l'ordre public
celles et ceux qui sont en haut lieu on
organise le désordre depuis maintenant
plus de 24 mois dans ce pays et nous en
venons à une situation de chaos
permanent comme nous la connaissons
encore aujourd'hui ou le dialogue n'est
plus possible
la parole s'est éteinte et la parole et
pourtant le premier levier pour que
s'exprime la démocratie et quand la
parole cette heure eh bien c'est la
violence qui prend qui prend la place ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui peut tenir
dans le dur et dans la durée nous ne
pouvons pas continuer à fonctionner
comme cela dans ce pays mais nous savons
non seulement que monsieur macron n'est
pas compétent vous restaurer le dialogue
le dialogue populaire mais en plus qu'il
ne le veut pas il ne le souhaite pas il
souffle en permanence sur les sur les
braises et maintenant qu'il est en
campagne pour 2022 il a beau essayer de
jouer dès à présent une campagne à
fronts renversés en se mettant du côté
est prétendument du peuple en dénonçant
les violences policières ou en disant
qu'il est contre le consensus de
washington vous savez cet ordre
néolibérale qui s'abat sur nous depuis
plus d'une trentaine d'années et qu'il
veut finalement refonder un capitalisme
qui serait à échelle humaine
eh bien nous savons d'expérience
désormais que tout cela ne sont que des
mots des mensonges et qu'il ne faut rien
entendre de de cela donc bien il va
falloir rompre avec cette cette
politique est d'une certaine façon avec
monsieur macro une manifestation donc
cet après midi on lisait qui au départ
était interné pour motif de crise
sanitaire on voyait il ya beaucoup de
monde
effectivement cet après midi le motif de
la crise sanitaire c'est celui qui me
remettait le plus que le gouvernement
selon vous non pas du tout le problème
pour ceux pour ce gouvernement c'est que
empêtré dans skins ans qu'il a eu à
subir cette semaine avec les violences
policières qui sont apparus aux yeux aux
yeux de tous il ne souhaitait pas
aujourd'hui avoir une manifestation qui
risquait de dégénérer et dans laquelle
les forces de l'ordre seraient
incapacité justement par la politique
qui est qui et qui est conduite mais en
essayant de contraindre le peuple il a
au contraire renforcé la volonté
populaire exprimée la soif de liberté
qui est la nôtre dans ce pays depuis
toujours mais plus encore aujourd'hui où
on essaie d'entraver cette cette liberté
par tout un arsenal législatif et donc
il a renforcé la volonté de toutes
celles et tous ceux qui se sont portés
dans la manifestation et qui expriment
leur détermination à pouvoir vivre
librement tranquillement et bien ce
faisant le gouvernement est pris à son
propre piège
il n'avait plus d'issue il a essayé de
contraindre mais le droit s'est imposé à
lui le tribunal administratif
et heureusement quand on voit le monde
qu'il y avait a permis que se déroule la
manifestation
et dans cette manifestation qui aurait
pu être largement plus encadré le
gouvernement a préféré
reculé à préfet m préféré mettre des
effectifs réduits autour du cortège et
ses incapacités c'est empêcher lui même
d'intervenir pour aller chercher les
casseurs quand il aurait dû le faire
cela fait des années maintenant il ya eu
un tournant le 1er mai 2016 au moment
des manifestations sur la loi travail
que les différents pouvoirs successifs
celui de monsieur hollande qui relevait
à l'époque mais aussi de monsieur
monsieur macron et puis désormais
directement celui de monsieur macron
laisse faire les casseurs en tête de
cortège parce qu'ils y voient une
manière de fragmenter l'arrière la
société et de pouvoir en faire un usage
communicationnel et bien cette façon de
faire n'est pas sérieuse
parce qu'aujourd'hui elle bute sur le
fait que y compris la volonté populaire
ne peut plus ne peut plus s'exprimer
c'est un puits sans fond et celui ci en
mon bonnet devrait bien être bouché